guys today we received new footage from
Avengers infinity war and a new TV spot
trailer that was released today before
we go into the trailer please remember
to subscribe to my channel to stay
up-to-date on Avengers infinity war the
trailer gives us a few more scenes that
reveals a little bit more about Avengers
infinity war check this out
[Music]
we're gonna need some out
my kid ventured him
okay let's dissect each new scene piece
by piece
in the first new scene that we have it's
actually new audio that we hear Banner
has just fallen into the sanctum
sanctorum and is telling Tony Stark dr.
strange and Wang that Thanos is coming
you can hear the distress and the pain
and his voice as he tells them this is
because he has just come from fighting
Thanos we get a very brief clip up here
where we see the Hulk yelling on what
looks to be the ship that him Thor Loki
and the rest of Asgard was on in which
the Hulk ultimately gets sent to earth
to warn the Avengers that Thanos is
coming and the next new scene we see the
Milano of which the guardians of the
galaxy are on we then see Peter quill
tell the rest of the guardians this
might be dangerous so let's put on our
mean faces we actually saw this scene in
San Diego comic-con and a trailer that
hasn't been released to the public yet
the guardians of the galaxy are coming
upon the destroyed ship that Thor and
the rest of Asgard was on this is where
the guardians of the galaxy find Thor
and take him aboard their ship they then
wake him which is a scene that we have
in the current trailers that are
released the next thing we have is of
Iron Man and spider-man which is a dire
scene but also kind of funny at the same
time
Tony realizes that they are in over
their head in which he says we're going
to need some help all right kid you're
an Avenger now and then he gracefully an
officially dubbed spider-man and Avenger
in this scene it appears like they're in
front of some sort of a portal so my
theory is is they're about to transport
to Titan the last new scene we have is a
Thor looking up at someone asking you
ready this scene looks a lot like other
scenes we have which are widely believed
to be Thor forging his new hammer
Stormbreaker
so who is he talking to my guess is
either a he's talking to teen group
because it's widely believed that the
handle of storm breaker is made out of
teen grits branches or B he's talking to
one of the dwarves of neduvaali
which is the planet that we believe him
to be on the dwarves and the devil air
forged his original hammer mill near so
it would make sense that he would go to
them too for
new hammer Stormbreaker these are all
the new scenes that we got today I think
they are SuperDuper fantastically
awesome what do you guys think about
them let me know in the comments below
and please be sure to drop a like and
subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date on Avengers infinity war Marvel and
all things superhero thank you so much
for watching and have a great day